sur le site de la spa j'ai repéré un
petit chat pour lequel j'ai eu un petit
coup de coeur
simplement il trouve pas paris il
s'ouvre un spa qui est à est à londres
à quelques heures de paris et bat
aujourd'hui il est huit heures du matin
on va le chercher pour appuyer sur ça je
vais acheter quelques accessoires des
histoires de matières petit canapé de la
[ __ ] des petites couches car elle est
toute petite rockette russe ex n est pas
contente
il peut le piquer il va être accueilli
comme un petit prince à l'orée de filmer
blanche en train de démarrer la voiture
c'est vraiment le même personnage de mr
vidéo te dire la personne qui conduit
une fois tous les huit ans alors comment
démarre déjà mais c'est la ceinture
sécurité calme toi même à fait détendue
au maximum alors là on quitte à amiens
pour aller à talons d'un autre ou la spa
ont fait le parcours du combattant pour
ferrer ce chat mais j'ai eu ce petit
coup de coeur donc on va jusqu'au bout
du délai a le vent souffle
une aventure qui sifflent
ainsi fou
tête s'envoler vu le vent n'a pu tout à
l'heure si on a un rôle y est on est
hyper vite ici à lui signé des éoliennes
dans la forêt je pense qu'on va
d'ailleurs une ferme nous croisons une
voiture après une heure de route en
solitaire plus que 530 m la bonne mort
et voilà après cinq heures de trajet on
tourne arrive enfin à la spa
bonjour maman chante et nathalie je
viens pour le petit chat pour les yeux
très bleus
bonjour je possède toutes les couleurs
des champs en même temps on est heureux
vraiment des hangars fils et moi tu n'es
faux pas ils s'en bat les couilles
bonsoir et le shaq que vous avez bien
donc c'est celui-là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà premiers contacts plutôt ratée en
corner ou coup - il milite pas
contrairement acteurs aulas le feeling
est présent il risque de se cacher
peut-être le premier jour mais c'est ça
la première année il se cache un peu non
[Musique]
j'ai capturé un pokémon je sais qu on
vit mieux et tu content
[Musique]
ok maladie jalès bien il a deux ans il
est extrêmement mignon un peu timide un
peu tendu mais je sens qu'il est à la
direction pour inscrire la justice un
projet c'est de fuir vers l'infini mais
ouais c'est 2
on sait qu'on est des gens très gentils
petit peu d'eau
prêt pour la route alors petit lapin on
voit là on sort de la spa on est resté
bien de ben on dirait que les chiens à
c'est un petit peu difficile parce qu'on
a envie de tous les adopter absolument
impossible et maintenant il reste plus
qu'à à lanières étape c'est de rester en
vie avec planches au volant jusqu'à
paris en trois heures encore entendu
qu'une seule fois le son de sa voix
ça souhaite faire
j'essaierai une heure de temps et j'ai
mis des gants pour nettoyer la gamelle
du shah avant tout propreté on dire
vraiment je lui fais un toucher rectal
on va bene hélas plus qu'une heure et
après vraiment tu vas être pekouz coucou
merlin la caméra
[Musique]
dans la famille
j'te
[Musique]
bon